just i think there's maybe a discrepancy
of the definition of submission i think
you guys have a perception of what they
mean by submission and i may have a
different one so can we kind of clarify
what we think submissions yeah what do
women think submission is because it's
normally women that have a problem with
the word so what do you actually think
it is
um i think submission is understanding
somebody else's strengths so if you are
a man and you're telling me babe i need
to go and get this job and you're going
to have to do this because this is the
plan and this is what you need to do i
guess i would submit in that in that
position because your planning is is
what you do best that's your skill
that's what you do if we're now in the
house and you're trying to tell me how
is the best way for us to spend money in
the house when i run the home then i'm
not going to submit to you trying to
tell me that because actually you need
to respect my role and i respect yours i
believe that's what submission is
submission is when you understand that
in respect somebody else's position
being in that situation specifically
ahead of you do you think do you think
of yourself as a submissive person
listen i dated nigerian for five years i
know what submission is and yes i am
submissive if if it makes sense i don't
submit just for the sake of things and
when things don't make sense i actually
am able to communicate clearly and
maturely enough to explain why this
doesn't make sense do you think you give
off submissive energy but that's not the
point what and this is the thing what i
feel like is my my strength and power as
a woman is actually a filter that i feel
gets the right people around me because
when you get to know me you understand
that this what i'm doing
is to test people because i need to know
that the man that i'm getting with is
emotionally mature enough to understand
that i can be a powerful woman but i can
also be a feminine woman that can take
care of a man and nurture him i can ask
you a question
are you single i am okay that's what no
no it's not you know why i'm single
because i was in a relationship for five
years and i finally decided to leave and
say actually you know what this man i'm
giving everything that i can i become a
robot for this person he didn't value me
did you did you file a police report i
never did because i thought protecting
him because i loved him so why didn't
you file when you left i didn't fail
because i don't need to he's a black man
i'd rather protect him in that way and
just walk away from the situation and
say you know what the universe will deal
with you i don't need to prefer but
earlier on you said that the reason why
you're single is because
you were a powerful woman and he
couldn't um you couldn't like um help
help your dreams or whatever it is you
said no and now and now you're saying
you left because he was are they
sprinting so which one is it i'll
explain to you why the situation go
abusive when you're dealing with
somebody that wants to be in the
starlight and wants to be you know the
superstar if you have a certain energy
that calls for attention it becomes a
problem i know how to speak to people
people are drawn to me and in a
relationship and as a woman that is also
beautiful that can look very bad
sometimes so when men come to speak to
me when women come to speak to me and
i'm giving a lot of attention it became
a problem and you know what sometimes i
i beginning i was like okay it makes
sense but after a while after i tried
the submission after i fulfilled the
role that you're meant to fulfill
especially because i was dealing with
the nigeria with a nigerian that has
very traditional values especially of
what the role of a woman is meant to be
i understood that that's not good enough
and that's actually what um i understood
is that at this point i know the problem
is no longer with me because i tried
everything i listened i tried
self-awareness do you think a lot
actually a lot more than than what
people think i speak like this because i
feel like it's important for a woman to
actually be able to give as much power
as man does so that can be educate
people to understand not all women are
the same not all women are going to be
lonely and not all women or women that
are single are the perpetrators
a woman is supposed to give as much
power as a man does what you just said
it's not that woman needs to give as
much power as a man that's what you said
though no a woman needs to be able to
give as much power but in her own way i
don't need to be sitting down in a room
with dick measuring with men i have my
own power as a woman and what power is
that my power is about femininity the
power of being able to speak
intelligently but quite simply without
having to prove points all the time yeah
but
men don't give a [ __ ] if you're
intelligent but the thing is they just
care if you're kind of
let me tell you something before i am
with a man i am myself if i have a
career if i have my own dreams in life i
don't expect to have to give all that up
because i have a home a man at home and
i have to be submissive i am powerful in
who i am but i can also be a woman that
is in a relationship and can be happy i
don't need to be showing my power and
take measuring with my husband that's
stupid so let's say for example you get
of a guy that's a one percent maybe
draco future one or any of that and he
said i want you to quit your job are you
going to quit your job
the thing is if it provides it depends
on the alternative it depends on the
alternative because answer the question
it depends on the alternative i can't
just tell you because future and drake
what they're going to offer okay
he says to me babe listen this is a guy
that you want to be with he has the
quote like this is the guy i don't know
what the guy is to you but like we don't
need to make it complicated it's not
future it's not drake it's just a
whatever your dream guy is he says quit
your job yes or no i'll be like what do
you mean to do then i'll cause i'll get
bored at home i'm not gonna lie
do you know what's so funny is that you
think you're submissive it's amazing
that you think it's a business
you're a masculine woman brother who
wants a guy to be on your own
what sense does it mean let me just
explain it to you okay because that's
your boss like submission is looking at
that man like he is your boss
and so but that that's because you're
not submissive like like i googled this
the definition of submissive it's the
act action of accepting or yielding to a
superior force or to the will or
authority of another person so it's
you're giving the man authority to tell
you to quit your job but not over
everything that's the whole point it
needs to be selective because that's but
okay that's that's that's probably
submission
but you want the total submission where
total submission does not make sense
because it's not every single time that
a man's decision to tell you to do
something is going to be right the
moment you start accepting to be
submissive over things that don't make
sense you're going to lose yourself yeah
but the things that don't make sense you
don't have to do that but the stuff that
do you make sense so you telling me to
quit my job without giving me an
alternative of what i'm going to do it
doesn't make sense
this is how how it would be okay it's
it's trusting his judgment so you saying
oh well it depends on all these factors
submission is saying you know what i
know you're a good man i picked you i
trust your judgment you pick your boss
okay who you're going to submit to so
but when you're coming in and saying
well i need to know all the details
that's not submissive it's not
necessarily about if a man says to you
right
listen at eight o'clock i'm coming to
pick you up put on your best dress and
your best shoes don't worry about it i
got you what are you gonna do cool so
when are you gonna be like yeah but
where are we going no what are we doing
who are we going to be with
us
that's what that is
that's what it sounds
this is the thing because when a man
does that
he's he's he's actually doing it to see
what you're like because if i can tell
you listen eight o'clock put your best
dress on your best shoes
don't worry about it and you say okay
baby oh that's something that's right
right there
no but wait wait wait wait we love that
[ __ ] but going on a date and quitting
your job is totally different no not
really even putting it in this is
babe quit your job and i said to you
babe
what's the alternative and you said to
me listen don't worry trust me okay wait
let's that's the number
you see what i mean because women the
same way that a woman
is reassuring because women want
stability as well that's one of the
things that women also want stability
because the future for a woman who is
going to be a mother and all of these
things requires a lot of stability so
you as the provider and the protector if
i say to you what's the alternative you
tell me don't worry babe trust me i got
you then the story is different okay if
you expect me to quit like this because
you told me to that's wrong okay so but
now you're switching it you're saying
okay i'll submit when you talk to me the
way i like to be talked no like listen
when a woman when are you gonna say you
could say no but that's what you said
when a woman says to you the same way
that um he said to you that he when he
asks you these questions is to see what
you're like when a woman asks you
certain question she doesn't really want
an answer she wants reassurance the same
way that she says babe do i look nice
you don't need to tell her yeah i like
your hair like there's no baby you're
beautiful that's all she wants to hear
if i'm asking you what you'll ask me to
quit my job what am i going to do you
say babe don't worry i got you that's
reassurance then i'm more likely to do
it because he confidently told me that
he has my best interests at heart and
that he's got my back so i'm not going
into black what do you mean your best
interest because if he loves me supposed
to have my best interests at heart and
if i ask him a question like this and he
tells me baby don't worry i got you then
i know that you love me and your
questions can ask your questions here
let's say for example you're
marrying a guy that's ambitious both of
you are building together you see if
you're an ambitious guy one of you guys
are gonna have to give up your dreams or
your jobs and support the other
so if you're not gonna do that it means
you're not a submissive woman because a
submissive woman is going to support
that guy until he makes it and then yeah
the guy is definitely going to bring you
up when he's there but if you can't do
that that means you're not a submissive
woman how am i not supporting my man but
i still do you think that do you really
think that i used to support somebody
you have to give up on everything do you
really yes
if you have a kid you have to give up on
a lot of stuff no i'll give you i'll
give you an example i'll give you so my
dad's a top one percent earner top top
one percent probably half a percent
actually he's very successful and my mom
was a teacher she was going to college
and she was dating him they were doing
distance and he said
you can transfer schools and be with me
or you can find a new boyfriend she
transferred to be with him
then she started a business he started
business she was teaching she was a
teacher she taught first grade he said
okay um i i need help with the business
quit she quit she got a top one percent
guy she got 10 kids
lives in like five houses but she
wouldn't have gotten that if she wasn't
submissive and so she said well but da
da da da da da da da da da it all
depends
i'm telling you this is how you sound
like this
because
at the time as well
no no he didn't seriously he was broke
with a ton of college debt no but i mean
the connection the love between them
yeah but seriously i don't it was what's
your name again
alva dinova seriously i really don't
think you understand how you sound i
really don't i think you think you sound
a certain way
but
you're not the way you're telling people
that you are okay i'll explain something
to you a bit differently the way i'm
explaining things to you now is because
we're going into detail when we're
talking about the actual interaction
this is now we're going this is almost
like i'm trying to educate people with
the behind the scenes if my man because
i've done this i was in a relationship
for five years i gave up a lot to
support somebody's dream i even went as
far as learning how to do sound
engineering because my boyfriend went to
be a rapper i went as far as that
because i wanted to support my man is he
a rapper that we know no not really so
you supported somebody i support but
dead rap no but guess what but guess
what and this is the beautiful thing so
you just put in some deadbeats no she's
still done it
i still did it to support my man i still
went above and beyond to learn a new
skill to support his dream
that's the whole point and even with all
of this and no matter how much i tried
it was not valued so what i'm trying to
say is that submission is you we need to
actually really clear it out and
understand that submission is not say
pick up and drop everything because i
told you so submission comes on comes
through trust comes through respect it
comes through love but as many of you
know i was just banned on tic tac and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible